good
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast today is Thursday in a
very long week Thursday May 9 9 it's a
great day it's just bright in New York
and sunny I'm feeling just like the sun
is shining out of my ass today and
that's it it is a very long week but
once it's Thursday we're going home now
we're home free
I know but it's just like Thursday
supposed to feel like but I don't feel
that way I feel that way cuz this the
first half of the week was very busy
catching up on some meetings etc today
we just have like some low-key things to
do we're recording a very fun patreon
episode today with jaunt are gone about
men I love fashion and really getting
into the weeds on everything and I'm
really looking forward to this expertise
because a lot of people have said that
we can use them ya know like apparently
I'm not what you would call like a
fashion it's fishy annatto which it's
just insulting but I guess it's good
that we have a fashion like kind of soar
alongside us just to give us a little
you know what it's back it's just I'm
not true like you are a fashion division
I mean [ __ ] rompers from Amazon like
if that's not a fashion aficionado then
I don't know what is that's a super cute
romper it's very 2019 Kim Possible it
also comes in a variety of colors so I'm
thinking now that I like the fit of
getting a few more did you buy it from
one of your favorite bloggers of course
I did and if you got a few more like do
will they get the Commission I don't
think so and just like to go back to her
Instagram story to find this web bub is
like too much work for me yeah you know
it would be the right thing to do it
would be the right thing see but if she
already got Commission off of this so
hottie is looking beautiful and
someone's making money that's always a
good thing I've been wearing like bare
legs for two days in a row with non
shaven legs and you know what it's can
you see my leg hair from there nope you
know what's just opening my eyes to it's
like no one can see your like hair so
why are we always shaving it no no one
can see our like hair until they can and
then it's like for that maybe you get
seated next to someone and the dinner
your leg brushes up against someone else
or you're outside and the light just
hits you just wrong and that it's just
there for the world to see but like you
have what blondes like hair that like
you it would take a lot it would take a
lot for someone to see your like hair no
I get away with so many more days of not
shaving than
most people with darker like hair from
where I stand right now like I could see
my own a black hair but like if I guys
matter I can see what looks to be like
hair follicles yes I guess it's what
looks to be that doesn't mean that they
are well yesterday was just like such a
depressing day for my self-esteem I
don't know what particularly went wrong
Jonny literally I've been feeling that
way for like a week and literally in the
car today I was like about to cry wait
you're gonna hear the funniest so sorry
so I just like put on my Instagram today
that I've just been feeling like
actually like a moose like and I feel
like I've been doing so many things to
try and make myself feel better like I
got my lips done like it made me feel
worse like I just can't get ahead of my
own insecurities and I put on my story
so much does anyone else ever just feel
like a lull in confidence in everyone
was like I was just waiting my Jam's and
they were actually making me feel better
I was like you're great you're beautiful
and someone wrote me this message they
were like don't be upset like you're
doing so much every day you know having
such an impact on acceptance I'm like
I'm I sort of freak like the way that I
look like that I need to be accepted
feel so much worse obviously that's only
one of my carping on all the other
beautiful messages right know yesterday
was particularly from the moment I went
woke up to the moment I went to sleep I
was just like not feeling myself like
first of all the way that dress I were
on the show yesterday like did me no
favors but I had a migraine so I just
had to be comfortable then we went to a
meeting whatever I put on to whatever
dress and then last night we went to a
restaurant opening and I was actually
looking forward to it I was getting my
hair blown out I was gonna you know have
the time to do my makeup pick out
whatever I wanted to wear and I did all
those things and I never felt worse I
was putting on these dresses and my legs
were so pale that I actually put on leg
self-tanner because like that's how
insecure I was feeling and then I just
wore pants yeah like I think maybe it's
the time of year like everyone's
transitioning out of like their winter
body's like pale legs hairy legs there's
something definitely in the air like
with this time of year where people just
like aren't feeling their best and I'm
like feeling it so hard and I don't ever
remember the last time I felt this way
and like it's a terrible feeling it's a
terrible feeling I'm feeling like I need
to start getting spray tans just for my
everyday life not just special occasion
you know what's so funny thank you for
reminding me I was actually thinking
about getting a spray tan today just
like for the weekend
I could be I could partake like at like
just the booth okay like I could partake
in that as well
have to get this out Tanner off my legs
yeah actually your legs do look good
thank you
which one oh my god oh my god now I
could see where I [ __ ] it all up you
used one from European whack Center but
I never even think that it works but
look at these streaks but it's not their
fault it's my fault cause I was just
like throwing it on like moisturizer I
wasn't actually thinking that it might
work I think I just need some Sun I
don't know like there's there's
something missing in my life and I can't
figure out what it is but I'm also just
being an ungrateful [ __ ] like I just
need to stop no but also I think the
issue is is that it's spring so we're
dressing for spring but it's still cold
and the sun's not out so like I'm
bearing arms but the sun's not like
shining down on me giving me a glow so
I'm like in the middle of winter with my
pale self and my legs yesterday I put on
a purple a light purple dress that I
almost wore and like if you just took a
picture of my legs so me the same color
is your dress
no like you would have thought it was a
seven year woman's I'm totally like I
don't know I don't know how to get out
of this funk but it's like starting to
take a toll um you know what I think we
need to do I think we need to go on a
trip where we get a suntan and then that
will carry us into the summer okay I
think so too but like I've recently
decided to make the decision to like
stop sitting in the Sun so much just cuz
like you know cancerous rays use me just
for sunscreen even then you don't get
air but we're like SPF 15 you'll get a
nice beachy glow you put in a little
more work but it's okay no I think I'm
just gonna say it's not like yeah yes
the Sun can be harmful but the Sun is a
wonderful organism I definitely need
some vitamin D for sure you know people
have been sitting in the Sun for years
totally people have also been getting
cancer for you know but like the Sun has
been around since the dinosaurs like
yeah no they're gone - baseball - or
just feel like in the spangs you're
wearing like dough cut it of course I
think I've actually officially outgrown
Spanx like I need something tighter
actually ordered something new today
it's like supposed to be Fupa specific
super friendly yeah
the worst is when like you're wearing
Spanx and you're complaining that you
feel fat and someone says well why don't
you put on Spanx well won't you eat my
ass well we transitioned from the
earlier this week complaining about
being sick - this week - today just
complaining about being ugly so this is
just the morning complaint so without
further ado if it's okay with everyone
we are going to stop complaining and we
are going to dive right into the fast
five story is that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast okay
first story little update
yesterday Megan and Harry have had their
baby and right after we wrapped
yesterday the name came out and name is
archiekins it's Archie Harrison
mountbatten-windsor I love the name our
chair do you think it's odd that Archie
I thought is more of like a nickname of
short for Archibald or whatever so yeah
it's interesting that they like it's
like naming your kid Jackie instead of
Jacqueline well like Viki they could
have done Archibald Harrison and called
him Archie or it's like naming your kid
and Nikki and sneetches but I think
they're just so progressive
I [ __ ] love the name Archie like I
would have been here it's like Theo's
name was almost Archie and he would've
been a wonderful Archie but I just loved
it for people as well and I'm loving
that now that it's a royal name it will
be a classic name forever
yeah so it's a safe name to name your
children anyone out there was like
worried but it is also like a lot of
dogs names mostly just Shannon books - I
was just gonna say it's like when I
think of Charlie I mean Charlie Archie I
always think of Shannon beador dog
because I loved the name so much and I
almost named CEO Archie or I think of
Riverdale there's just like so many
things it's like when I think of George
I only think of Prince the little prince
I sometimes think of George
Stephanopoulos but that's it you don't
think of Curious George no I don't like
George into the jungle they've pretty
much owned that name then for like
Archie I think of Archie from Riverdale
I think of Archie the dog like Archie
the comic like there's just a lot of
things I think of before I think of
Megan Marcos maybe maybe that's what she
wanted
yeah and I'm so here I'm so here for a
night I love the name I think it's so
cute and I'm and it has homage to
Archibald which is apparently an
ancestor of Princess Diana's so they're
paying their respects is that how you
pronounce that word Archibald Oh Maj
that's home edge no you said like a hard
G you said a maje I said oh my I say G
but I feel like that's an [ __ ] I
think Olivia says homage I think I
pronounced this thing's weird she says
her Oshima whenever a knows its
Hiroshima we open on sensors but I say
Oh Maj Maj homage for my Zig modge podge
oh gosh Magog bookies reveal just 60
bets were placed on Archie had a hundred
to one odds amounting to exactly a
hundred and thirty dollars whoo what was
the most bet on name ooh
Arthur James fill up an Albert Arthur
wasn't super off I feel like the kid's
name could have been Arthur and Archie
for short no oh yeah it was like they
were cat
so they went down the path of Arthur
when they landed on Archie it's like
Harry's real name is Harold Harrison is
that why he's Archie Harrison Oh duh
mountbatten-windsor it's weird that
Prince William was never called will and
it's weird the whole mountain of it all
because if you watched the crown that's
Prince Philip's family name and he
wanted his wife to take his name and she
was like going to it was a whole thing
and then Winston Churchill was like you
can't take his name like the winces it's
a bigger thing than you and him so now
he's hyphenated I just can't believe
that the great-grandparents are like
still alive you know I know as like
Jewish people who like barely have
grandparents and we even know grandma
here yes I just can't even imagine
having two great grandparents like what
a life yeah what a bloodline what a time
what a time so much family so much
family so much heritage so much
intergenerational activity you know
that's the thing about being roads like
the internet generational activity is
always poppin but that's also like the
Kardashians have MJ and like she's there
I think about that a lot of kids
great-grandmother like that's so special
totally anyways excited for the whole
Windsor family Oh Harry's full name is
Henry that's weird I actually love the
name Henry and I'm gonna put it out
there as a possible name for one of my
children okay yeah you're gonna clean
that yeah I'm gonna claim a few actually
if we're just doing that right now
um I do like Henry I also like Harry but
it can of both I think I like Harry
better Harry Dubin is like slightly
burning that for everyone though I also
like uh you know one like you like a
name I think I've said this on the show
before then you meet some of what that
name like and automatically like it's
the worst name ever of course like I
have had a name in my soul forever and
then I met a girl you know who it is
right no I'll tell you later you know
who - no as I say it like she's a
popular Instagrammer 900g the same name
100% though I have like there were two
names that I was obsessed with one of
them I will not say because it's been
ruined and the other one was Snow which
no one likes but I've loved it for years
now so if I still love it when I have a
better I might name it not but now I'm
actually I've kind of rerouted on my
baby names and I might be going down a
path of like a theme and I love a theme
yeah but see the thing that if you're
changing up your baby names like so much
like trendy it's like maybe maybe you
should go for something a little bit
more classic no but it's not trendy it's
like
until CNA my might I love that name and
then I look at the history of them like
have people been being named this for
years what's the oldest person with this
name and what's the youngest person with
this name Jackie this is the first time
in my life I'm gonna say this you just
talk to so fast like I actually didn't
understand you you just swallowed like
four words
what's words I don't even know what you
just said watch words no sorry let me
just put it out there just cuz in case
any of the sisters want to steal it like
I have proof that I had these names
first
so Harry Henry one of those two i just
weird i only think of boy names maybe
that's like a sign i only think of girl
names so weird
i have maybe my son's will date your
daughter's name
I love Reuben for a boy with the short
ruby but I also have Ruby for a girl i
if I could I would like it goes with
what I'm doing an avenue that I'm going
down and I would I would love to take
Ruby no I know but like Reuben it's like
such like a nice Jewish like of the
tribe it's a very shy grandfather's name
and it's like I think it's better suited
for a man well what curse I've been
trying also like the name Michael which
was our dad's name right one person
can't have all the family meet that's
usually I got I got ribbon I want ribbon
please I'm just putting it up putting it
up and I'm putting out there that I want
Ruby so welcome every room been in a
Ruby no that's sucks so no you could
have a max in a Ruby question could we
have a Ruby and max I don't like the
name max okay but yes the name that we
referred to is it's probably the same I
met someone a few years ago with this
name and was so like disgusted by her
like her just whole vibe was so terrible
that I immediately hate the name and it
had been on my list since I met a girl
in middle school and it was her middle
name and I'm like that's the coolest
name yeah and no I can't do it anymore
so like annoying Instagram thirst
monsters are just like out here ruining
names you know why he it was great
he he's someone who could bear the name
room it it's really meant like a strong
you know powerful person yeah and then
it's like it's a Clay Aiken it's what I
can couldn't be named Reuben here's the
problem whatever your name is it's like
you look up to people with that name
look at me
Jackie oh so if you're if the person
that you know that you ruined the name
for you is a public figure then your son
or
we'll look at that person and like you
know relate to them and might want to be
like them and that's the problem right
so growing up I was inspired by Claudia
Schiffer because she was literally the
only person on planet earth with the
name and I was like okay I guess I'm a
model
yeah and that's I think where my
confidence stems from like just thinking
I was born from the namesake of a model
from thinking you were Claudia
Schiffer's right no and like any time an
older person met me they were like
what's your but my clutter like lengshan
for and I'm like that's the one
so I guess that kind of model mentality
really stuck with me throughout the
years right so I believe that Megan and
Harry's baby will be watching a good
amount of Riverdale in their time I
really did I mean I didn't stop seeing
memes about like I achieved memory now
Betty like so stupid but I was really
surprised I catch a patent say anything
cause like he's a funny guy and like I
just thought he would have a dress down
his Instagram stories or something
totally and he did a weird Instagram
story yesterday about Kylie lip kits so
let's not like why wouldn't you
something that it's just more question
it's in a club right the Archie Club
yeah and then there's like another show
that's like an adult show called Archie
right you know it there is a show called
Archie that's like has nothing to do
with baby watch Netflix show dead to me
no but I've been hearing great michigo
I make check it out me too it may check
it out but I just feel as if it's
important to honor the names of those
before you but I don't like when people
like like copy the name so much you know
it's like you can be inspired by it yeah
you know it's just important to keep
your heritage you know a good part of
your of your future and that's what
23andme it's all about all about that's
what I did my 23 to me and I immediately
felt more connected to my ancestry to my
heritage and to my intergenerational
relationships which is so important its
key its key and I think 23andme is
actually a great gift for Mother's Day
because if you don't know where you come
from how can you know where you're going
well if you have a GPS so you can know
where you're going by your soul I
actually think 23 Emmys are great and
like thoughtful gift for Mother's Day
and for a limited time only 23andme is
taking $30 off their health and ancestry
kit until make their teens at 23andme
health and ancestry kit is the perfect
gift for Mother's Day celebrate what
makes mom special with personalized
genetic insights on her health traits
and more with twenty three Emmys heltah
ancestry ket she can discover how her
genes may influence her health and more
with over 125 personalized genetic
reports that feature information on her
traits and health like Jeanette genetic
weight caffeine consumption
sleep mood
and much more interesting with twenty
three Emmys trade report mom can learn
how her DNA influences her facial
features taste smell and other traits oh
my god this Mother's Day give 30% off
$30 off excuse me twenty three Emmys
health and ancestry at 23andme dot-com /
toast that's the numbers two three and
me.com slash toast
$30 off 23andme dot-com / toast and
offer ends on May 13th so if you need a
last minute Mother's Day gift you can
get $30 off your 23andme kit if you go
down speaking of descendants you want to
hear an interesting factoid that I just
read in this article that is the middle
name Harrison derives from Harry's son
Oh duh and so does the last name Goldman
derived from the gold man the man of
gold yes yes another friends reference
that you want to understand but Phoebe
made a great call once it's like there's
last names at Goldman and you know
Bergman but spider-man is why is he
spider-man okay speaking of people with
great names that are great role models
you know who I'm talking about great
name great role model Kim Kardashian
great guess Olivia culpo Oh blast Olivia
her name is Olivia she's which is a
great name it's a great name and if you
want to give birth to a winner I would
recommend naming your kid Oh meet you
Olivia cocoa blast married celebs who
messaged her after Danny Amendola split
said again Olivia culpo is blasting
married celebs who slid into her d-ends
after she split with Danny Oh Olivia
culpo is feeling tempted to call out
some of the men who slid into her diems
after she split from ex Danny Amendola
she revealed on the Jenny McCarthy show
Wednesday quote you know how many people
I want out the social-media influencer
said quote nothing irks me that's what
she's getting in try now who wrote this
page six okay she's fully a model model
celebrity mobo
mogul yeah nothing irks me more than
when someone slides into my DMS she said
messaging her on Instagram is her number
one red flag warning those who have
reached out with her reach out to her
with a girlfriend her wife I'm going to
put you on blast I really want to screen
cap all of them and just be
I hate all of you guys tell your wives
that they need to leave the model added
I'm offended that you think that I would
even take the bait honestly
although Coco said repeatedly she wants
the blasts of famous married men who
flirted with her she didn't reveal any
names
shady I feel like celebrity teams are
just so interesting so interesting and
like okay let's play a fun game yeah
who's messaging Olivia culpo I feel as
if it's definitely athletes oh my god
imagine if it was like Eric Decker I
know you know why I got that vibe of
like someone in the country world just
because like I don't know he's not that
stupid no oh my god you're a by the way
to do this you have to be a borderline
like dumb yeah Sydow stupid not even to
be a married person messaging girls on
Instagram which is idiotic but also
messaging fellow celebrities who have a
platform to out you yeah I wish she like
would have outed them just because like
that would've been epic but she's
probably there are people like probably
shaking in their boots you know no like
to their wives and beds like going to
sleep but can't sleep because let me go
post keeping them up okay let's play
another game
who should message Olivia : Matt Harvey
I need to really think on this we talk
about this all the time and they still
can't find a man who's worthy of her
terms
because maybe like it really is like a
blessing to be so beautiful and like
perfect because like there's literally
no one out there good enough smart and
talented and ambitious and beautiful and
Busy Philipps
tonight no longer tomorrow no I don't
say she was busy yesterday but
tomorrow's look at me tomorrow's wide
open well may 16th ladies for final show
yeah I actually will be watching it cuz
I want to see what cringy like song she
does with her nightgown yeah I think
she'll just do the ones crazy you know
it's so funny it's like ever since her
show got canceled her show has been in
the news more than ever like I've heard
so much about busy tonight now that it's
canceled yeah like the the people's only
started to care like once was too late
she was nominated for critical choice
and she opened up last night
Oh two nights ago cuz they passed this
like new terrible law about abortions in
Georgia and she opened up the she's got
an abortion I think it was like a hoping
to help others which was brave very
brave um did you walk to her honey last
night no I mean I thought you might
watch it it'll be a late night we had a
late night it was crazy
it was I will watch today the outreach
aspect of it reminded me because they do
a charity event and it's bonkers like I
literally like hit like it was crazy
okay I didn't watch very well finally
but it wasn't even like crazy in the
house I sort of why it was like a what
is going on
smarter fight it was so crazy oh and did
you watch the week before where Ramona
was like social-climbing at that no I'm
too much mind oh okay you got a catch I
will catch up you gotta catch up so we
can talk about nothing
okay next story next three stories are a
little different you know just switching
things up around here
massive cachet of a thousand guns seized
from a bel-air mansion connected to
Gettys a man was arrested Wednesday
after authorities seized more than 1,000
guns guns from what kind orbit yet no I
think it was extra read all about him in
whole meals authority said officials
received an anonymous tip about a person
illegally manufacturing and selling guns
in a home in the hundred block of North
Beverly Glen Boulevard said Officer Mike
Lopez as part of an ongoing to an
investigation the Bureau of Alcohol
Tobacco Firearms and Explosives and the
LAPD served a search warrant to the home
at 4:00 a.m. the HTF said in the
statement that its agents searched the
home after discovering an individual
illegally selling firearms outside the
scope of federal firearm license at the
individual possesses the federal agency
added that they have no reason to
believe the public is in danger the man
whose name has not been released but he
was arrested on suspicion of unlawful
transportation and giving lending or
selling an assault weapon according to
LAPD um okay so I requested to talk
about this story because I've literally
never in my life like seen a photo of a
thousand guns yeah and it's shock King
and like it's just a weird cuz like all
these people were like this guy was just
like living next to all these celebs
probably like waving to them on his way
home and it's like it's like the lovely
bones
you know it's like you to see your
neighbor he's just Stanley Tucci yeah he
walk inside his house and he's a freak
with the doll fetish was Susie salmon
lying in his basement and he's Stanley
Tucci Stanley oh my god I will literally
never think about Stanley Tucci other
than when you convinced us you were
sending XM in coach
I was maybe was that sure leg room no
you were we were on
flight home from LA the day after the
Oscars our Golden Globes and I was
saying that's to Stanley Tucci like I
was in the window and he was in the
aisle and we were in an exit row service
extra legroom and I was watching
spotlight and he was in ok I watched pot
like that slide as well and I just have
to say what a movie but there is so we
all believe Jackie even though it didn't
make any sense and he was just nominated
for an Oscar and I was coming back to
New York on coach no I don't think so
I mean I get back we would literally
were G playing I look at Jackie there's
a bald guy like he and he had glasses he
was so not Stanley I will the only thing
I didn't measure up was he was a little
child Hearst what I thought Sammy sushi
would look like but it was totally him
but still this Yugi is like a true actor
do you know what I mean cuz only like
someone as talented and dynamic as him
could play The Devil Wears Prada like
assistant designer while also like crazy
serial killer the lovely bones while
also Hunger Games writer broadcaster to
the stars interesting I love him if you
live in a movie it's a good movie that's
true like whatever Stanley Tucci puts
his approval I'm like I will say maybe
even in theaters yeah I was actually
listening to some talk radio this
morning in the car Neuwirth speaking of
spotlight the Pope passed a new law
ordinance and anytime I hear like the
Pope saying something to the what are
they called
they the people the the priests I'm just
like oh so it's about assault and it was
oh then he put that's a new law that
like all priests and figures and have to
report sexual assault like and bring it
all the way up and that whistleblowers
will not be punished and it's just like
that whole thing is still so crazy to me
no and you know what it's actually
annoying me please okay please it's like
it's a church you know it's supposed to
be a safe space and it's been exposed so
many times and you know I was actually
had to stop process yesterday with
Michael Jackson cuz Madonna came out and
she was like what happened to being
guilty to proving innocent and it's like
I just thought Hollywood and I say the
opposite innocent sorry that's what I
meant um but it's like funny that that's
what you think now because that's the
one that we don't know it's like
Hollywood really shapes my culture and
shapes like the the way people think so
like now I've just kind of been like
yeah we believe survivors cuz that's
what like all the celebrities and like
and you should you should believe
victims like who speak out against
assault
so that's where my mindset was at
because I've been I think persuaded in a
positive way by Hollywood but then it's
like okay Michael Jackson survivors
should be believed they're like oh no we
never said that are you talking about
Madonna's like what is with this you
know with the world turning onto him I
thought you were innocent to improve of
guilty I'm like well you said before we
should believe a song so I'm just
feeling conflicted by what I'm supposed
to believe because Hollywood tell me one
thing and then they're doing another so
it's like who should I be influenced by
and it is so true right now because it's
like really Hollywood at least they
pretend to be like they do what's right
and what's just and they try and be on
the right side of history you know it's
so corrupt behind the scenes the face
they put out it's like we are good and
righteous and there are so many people
in Hollywood who are good who are trying
to push a lot of their way or use their
platform but there's still so much that
goes on that's so dark so a lot of like
what I believe I'm like what and my
beliefs like change over the years
always but I really find myself like
heavily influenced by what celebrities
say just cuz like I love pop culture and
I'm just like really like heavily
persuaded by by their opinions so it's
like I mean I didn't even think of
sexual assaults like as much as I do now
like when I was like a teenager like it
just like wasn't as you know heavy of a
conversation but now it's it's in every
conversation time's up and it's great so
I'm like you know yeah I'm sorry I never
even thought about before but like of
course we believe survivors even though
like in the law of the court you're
innocent until proven guilty but no you
should believe survivors is very brave
of them and Hollywood helped me see the
light and then I'm like okay but so why
doesn't that pertain to Michael Jackson
right you know right do you think it's
because they're men and like no because
even oh the oh because the victims are
men yeah like maybe or not even maybe
subconsciously it's like we believe
survivors because more often than not
survivors are women it now that and now
that the survivor is here I'm in like a
lot of trouble reconciling now I thought
of it like that I thought a bit more
because it's big right I I think that -
I think it's like a combination of
things and also I just think it's a mass
amount of hypocrisy they get me to me
too for sure for sure double double down
the hypocrisy over here totally I'm glad
that this story has God just wish
someone would explain it to me like when
do we believe survivors and what are you
innocent until proven guilty I think
every case is different and so yes like
believe survivors but then there are
those stories that come out like
remember that roles that are awful that
like this
credit so many survivor Jessie and then
it makes that statement we're like we
believe survivors it makes it people
able to like you know poke holes in that
yeah so each case is different but I
think overall like believe people who
are brave and putting themselves out
there and saying things that they have
no nothing to gain nothing to gain from
yeah you know just find this is the
Michael Jackson of it all really
interesting and see do you ever watch
the keepers on play no I can't oh my god
I can't you would have so many so many
more opinions ahead like a low threshold
for things like that I know but like all
I think about know is like all the gory
details of Michael Jackson's assault
because they were so in depth in that
documentary that like it was actually a
little too much like I was like sick the
keeper I'm just gonna like brief
synopsis at the keepers and just talk
about it today it's the documentary
series so I think it's like six to eight
episodes and it starts with this nun who
was found murdered in somewhere in New
England she was a nun at a school and so
the people who are looking into why she
died uncover a whole series of other
things so it starts with her death and
who killed her but and they never even
solved that they just find out what she
died for and it was like there was so
much abuse going on in the school that
she worked for and like the abuse like
the girls in school who were abused like
it went so deep but not only would she
go to the parish or the priest or
whatever and like he would abused her
but like he would bring in like local
police officers and it's like and they
would abuse her and it's like when you
can't trust your religion and a trust
law enforcement like oh my that's
horrible you can't go to anyone you
cannot go to anyone that's hard and like
then they like a tactic of like a lot of
the priests who would abuse children is
like they can't go to their parents
because their parents rely so heavily on
the church right like they take away
their parents they take away religion
they take away belief yeah and they take
away the law like what do you have left
I can't watch stuff like that it's
Harvard so anyways I'm glad that
ordinance is finally passed Pope Francis
but like how was sexual assaults just
like ever just like you know oh you
don't report it don't tell me that right
I read over a law where it was like you
know don't run it up the chain no
totally just switch them to another
school I can and they shent and I went
fourth story interesante
I love talking about her because I don't
know how I feel
about her Amanda Knox to return to Italy
for the first time since acquittal I
have to tell you like I am completely
well versed in all things pop culture
celebrities and I literally know nothing
about Amanda Knox like there's just one
documentary that explains it all that's
all I know about her did she kill
supposedly her roommate in Italy when
they were abroad and she's just a girl
from America yes who went abroad and so
she got away with it she was in jail for
a long time in Italy but then she wasn't
convicted and now she's home and like
making a life in America and it's so up
in the air about what happened do you
think she did it like I really don't
know to the documentary swayed like one
way um she was in it so it definitely
makes you sympathetic towards her and
what she went through and she definitely
was probably treated unfairly by the
media but if she is a murderer than that
that's what you guys write then then
that's not unfair but if she isn't then
you feel so bad so I definitely think
it's somewhere in the middle where like
she knew more than she let on because
she did lie along the way but she was
also like in interrogations under
distress and sometimes you just say the
thing they want you to say so that
they'll stop asking the question yeah
after like so many hours that's what I
remember about the documentary but
anyway she was invited to attend a June
conference organised in Modena
by the criminal chamber of the northern
city and the Italy Innocence Project so
I guess they assume she's innocent
honestly the Italy and it's a project
sounds like something Amanda Knox
started to make it's like the Italy
Innocence Project for people whose names
begin with a and end with a Amanda Knox
is returning to Italy for the first time
since she was convicted and imprisoned
but ultimately acquitted in the murder
and sexual assault of her British
roommate in the hilltop university town
of Perugia the American was invited to
attend a conference June 14th and 15th
organized in Modena by the criminal
chamber of the northern city and the
Italy Innocence Project which seeks out
people who have been convicted of crimes
they did not commit Knox will be
speaking on the role of the media in
judicial errors on the last day of the
conference okay she could probably speak
to that should we go and cover it like a
live toast from the Amanda Knox
Innocence Project I don't know like I
just don't want to be tangled up with
him in Knox and then it's like if she
did do it like I don't want you know you
know what's so crazy to think about like
if the toast was around well Amanda Knox
was in college like maybe she would've
been a toaster or like what would have
been our take on what was
you know I always like to think like
would I have thought you know was Monica
Lewinsky complicit or was she a victim
right like would I have been one of the
people who like Monica Lewinsky talks
about now is like having like destroyed
her right so when we were on Access
Hollywood like her I was on something
oh yeah no it's not Hollywood the entire
episode like leading up was like they
kept teasing this documentary they were
doing on Monica Lewinsky and they like
we're getting sneak peeks of it and it
really got me thinking I'm like I wonder
what my stance would have been like was
she just like ass Lizzie intern or was
she taken advantage of like honestly I
don't know but she was treated like a
[ __ ] what I think she was just a kid
right you know and it's weird that like
Amanda Knox is famous for being like oh
alleged murderer I'm like Monica
Lewinsky it's like famous for being an
intern who had sex with the president
you know like there's just weird things
to be famous for yeah it's all its own I
watched her on like a piece of her
interview on John Oliver and it's like
okay John Oliver was on then he would
have been going in on her as much as
anyone Andy Cohen has her own much
happens live and I always think like I
wonder what watch shop inside would've
been saying about this like she would've
been the jackal of the week totally yeah
so it is interesting if the Monica
Lewinsky situation happened in 2019 it
would be treated different they should
be treated differently and spoken about
differently as a woman was in in the 90s
yes
times have changed right we've evolved
or have way Michael Jackson who knows
anyways then I was thinking there was a
question in the toaster like if you
could have dinner with three people dead
or alive who would they be
I saw and I have the obvious choices are
obviously like Joan Rivers Taylor Swift
Taylor Swift Kim Kardashian etc but
honestly I want to hear from JonBenet
Ramsay okay the Amanda Knox's roommate
and Madeleine McCann and I want to know
what happened and then I'll make a
documentary also mrs. Anthony's daughter
mrs. Anthony mrs. Casey okay yeah but my
daughter's never here Caylee Oh
confusing I think um yes but all that we
fund then you also get to dinner with a
bunch of three-year-olds so not fun you
know I don't think you'd be fine but I
would get I would get the information we
get the true story and like you know we
could close the book on a lot of these
things
actually think I would prefer just for
like this hypothetical scenario to have
dinner with Kris Jenner more than I
would Kim Kardashian I feel as if Kris
Jenner is truly evolved do you have more
to learn from from yeah and like if I
asked her just question they would have
to be honest with me about like anything
that I wanted I would just like ask Kris
knows everything you know Kristin knows
best yeah I don't know I think like
finding out some of the greatest
unsolved mysteries
Oh in Amelia Earhart what happened where
are you
me and Jackie on the street saw the
Chris Lee's we did who did we see the
dad the son I only recognize the dad I
could see that face a mile away and that
ever since I saw him on the street I can
I know he's in New York
I keep thinking everyone is chris
Christie you know what like their show
plays on every [ __ ] Network and I've
never seen an episode I kind of like it
I I never really got into it I watched
one episode and I thought they were like
too mean to their kids so I turned it
off no yeah he's like an unnecessarily
strict dad with like 4 to 5 of their
kids are just like good when their kids
are good except the kids chase is like a
monster okay I think when he was a
teenager he was like I was like sneaking
out and stuff like he deserved to be
punished like said I was like littering
God's child and like she was always
being punished yeah yeah I think I'm
agree and it's like I was punished so
much as a child I don't watching on TV
I'm glad those days are behind me
yeah agreed yeah it didn't do it for me
okay the final story speaking of
misbehaving children
hold on CNBC you know what Nicole Brown
Simpson at that dinner no but I feel
like we know what happened to her I feel
like we know what happened to Caylee
Anthony just because Casey wasn't
convicted does I don't have questions
about what happened yes so like Solange
and also we need to be there I mean like
what happened in the elevator that would
be a great one so I would go JonBenet
because I also I could write a book
about dinner called my dinner with Jon
Benet anything you take a picture they
should be ghosts of Sneetches past so I
don't know how would like come out but I
would try is this insensitive I don't
think so I don't know I don't like this
one's happened once where we posted a
picture of dominating people were like
too soon yeah no it's like it's been 20
years and all I'm trying to do is get
justice for her and always say was that
how did she look like Gemini yeah and
people were like it's too soon um so
Dominic who write about called my dinner
with Jon Benet Ramsey and tell
everything that happened it's so funny
how there's like sometimes like no
threshold for like when you can joke
about something like at one of my shows
that made a joke about like who's the
president I got assassinated JFK or like
they tried to assassinate him they did
assassinate him JFK or Abraham Lincoln
JFK and people were like oh it's like
what
what we need joke about it was like 50
years ago yeah I guess not it depends on
this joke but like no all I was saying
was that like I feel like if I was a
powerful person I people would be trying
to assassinate me all the time like John
Kennedy and then Jackie O would be like
it's funny joke yeah it was a funny joke
like nobody that is funny and like I
forgive a town it was like I what we
were turning totally no I think I give
you a pass on that okay speaking of
missing children walmart raises minimum
age to buy tobacco to 21 as pressure
mounts to curb illegal sales to minors
Walmart will increase the minimum age to
buy tobacco products to 21 starting July
1st Walmart is also in the process of
discontinuing sales of fruit and dessert
flavored cigarettes the FDA in April
threatened to find Walmart and other
retailers for illegally selling tobacco
to products to minors well there's a
difference between like illegally
selling tobacco products to people who
are under 18 and then having to raise
the age to 21
that's just opening now more minors so
does that include jewel
so now jewel products they'll only be
tobacco flavors and you can't buy it
until you're 21 oh so they're really
like cracking down oh yeah yeah yeah I
honestly like whenever I hear about
these things like these rules used to
affect me when I was a kid just like
trying to get high you know but now I'm
an adult I can do whatever I want and
it's like sorry kids see you later I'll
see you the next party well I got a
jewel for the first time before
stagecoach what did you feel like in the
boat a guy like buying a job first of
all they carted me and I was like how
old you have to be and they were like 21
it's like okay so I don't even look 21
thanks boys and then I was just learning
so much more and I was like how much you
have to be to buy a pack of cigs these
days in the city it is 21 which is like
so old MIDI or something funny I went to
go buy a jewel before stagecoach to I'd
like this bodega buy my house like a
literary dress like an actual like slob
I had Theo and I'm just like please
nobody talked to me and I'm paying and
the girl in front of me had just paid
she's like getting her stuff together
and of course she's like a toaster oh
yeah and she's like totally judging me
for the dishes like really jewel I'm
like [ __ ] you got wrong bottle lights
in your hands you're [ __ ] trash shop
god that's crazy do you want to make
sure I was like sure that's so crazy no
I
and it's not my problem cuz I'm 26 years
young but uh
kids these days like 21 is kind of old
to not be able to buy cigarettes but see
it's still weird cuz what they want to
change the age for it so he's like they
keep wanting to make it older and older
for like alcohol cigarettes but they
want to rip lower the age for voting's
yeah that's weird I like I think it
should be the like at a certain age you
get all of the responsibilities and all
of the privileges so voting and
cigarettes and alcohol should be hand in
hand and I think that'll be when you're
18 yeah but I think cigarettes and
voting on a teen and drinking at 21 I
think the drinking age is fine maybe I
wouldn't advocate for anything less but
then do you think then that means what
I'm saying is and I don't know if I
would agree with what I'm saying is that
the voting age should be 21 or the
drinking it should be 18 no voting age
being 21 it's like a little old right
that's really old
I just looked on Twitter they were
trying to someone suggested like
lowering at a 16 I'm like when I was 16
like I was truly a Church treat like a
literally getting high on my own supply
like yeah I was not in any way shape or
form like capable to make decisions like
that no I think the voting age at 18
like seems to be working and it seems
like a good year and the drinking age of
21 everyone seems okay with so now the
question is age of tobacco that's what's
changing what are your thoughts um I
feel like as a society we're smoking so
much less like too little too late to be
changing the thing you know yeah like
maybe 10 years ago like when you would
smoke inside and you knew the effects
but like people just love to smoke and
smoking was very much a part of culture
maybe then it would have been a time for
21 year olds like nobody cares anymore
yeah but now there's joules online so
it's like it's so stupid
but this the more that like when you
raise that age there's now there's three
years of people will have to go about it
illegally and now people are committing
more crimes because they're not gonna
stop smoking just cuz you raise the age
do you believe the broken window theory
which is which is like I think and I
always get it wrong when it but I think
it's like Thoreau is talking about it on
Blue Bloods it's like if you
decriminalize like really small crimes
like public urination which it's like
you're not gonna go to jail for that but
like you get thrown in the drunk tank
like if you decriminalize those little
things like and you let those slide it
leads to like much bigger like in
society so it's like a broken window
it's like a little crack and then it's
like a big so it's like if you don't
make a big deal out of little things
then the big
it's become like so much more frequent
understood and they believe it to an
extent however I think there's a
difference between decriminalizing
something and letting it slide like I
think that public urination should be
something that you get worried about
getting arrested for me to um otherwise
people would like men mostly but we're
like publicly yearning all the time the
example is like people who go under the
subway and don't pay for it they just go
under the turnstile like should you get
a fine for that yeah yeah it's illegal
you see like because why then ever why
would I ever behind subway card you know
and then it's like I'm the [ __ ] who's
paying for the subway right ya know like
you should gotta find for it the
punishment shouldn't be like massive but
enough to make people not do it same
with public urination however if you are
an officer and you find someone publicly
urinating like I think it's okay to let
it slide on a case by case yeah yeah
yeah depends on if you have to make your
quota yeah and also do you want to just
touch someone who just peed that's where
my head's at right anyways that was our
fifth story and like what it robust
episode today just talking about like
politic politics policy policy um you
know society sexual assault sexual
limitation criminal justice reform
alcohol tobacco etcetera etc twitting
watch New York I will do my best to
catch up a little bit later today okay
but what else checking I've been up for
literally 17 hours yeah we went to a
really cool event this morning that we
can tell you about next week's
confidential we just had India's what is
actually quite educational
educational and pertinent to our city it
was nice to be in a business conference
where once where like I actually knew
what people were talking about and like
it actually related to me like I was I
felt like I was back in the classroom
like learning things that will be useful
and we have a lot of entrepreneurial
toasters so I feel like we might really
benefit from this platform that we are
finding out about know but also just
toasters will benefit from of course
I'll find out soon okay Craig but Jack
essentially not our secret project it's
someone else's yes what are we to be
like whistleblowers I feel like in the
last 24 hours I've learned so much about
new technology yeah and you know in an
NDA sort of way they talked about my
extremely disappointing experience of
paper goods yesterday paper source yeah
I've been talking about how excited I
was to go to paper source for like three
days as if a Pyrus ambassador I'm here
for you taking them down no it was just
like first of all we arrived on what
could have been the worst day for
planners because like something happened
yesterday where all the new 2020
planners were released
in stores yet so it's like I went on the
day looking for a 20/20 planner but like
I couldn't find one so she's like yeah
the planners are in the back on
clearance I'm like why would the 20/20
planners be on clearance and I go there
and they like [ __ ] 2018 calendars I'm
like [ __ ] I need 20/20 so like come
back next week I'm again I'm gonna come
down a hundred blocks just get a [ __ ]
platter so we ended up spending $80 8-0
now I'm a new planner I put the toasters
like what are the best brands and
everyone said Erin Condren Erin Condren
and I went it's like totally customized
well it's like you like monthly you can
make it monthly cards I did weekly
vertical you like you can really edit
the pages like how you want then you
could choose like a bunch of their
designs for the cover or you can upload
your own image so you know I uploaded an
image of Theo I saw and I'm just like
really excited it was $80 like I didn't
even wince I didn't realize that the
inside is customizable I'm so happy with
my at a glance monthly but I went to at
a glance before they told me about Erin
Condren and I was just like so super
really disappointed like by the at a
glance aesthetic and so not you know
it's not it's not cool or cute or
anything but it's like what's on the
inside is what I need yeah I just I
really enjoyed my experience at Erin
Condren and that's it
I just can't believe like you were in
the toaster could be yesterday like
asking if we should make a subgroup for
people there was a choice of planners um
and like first like there was a time
when like you just weren't on the
planner grind you know the thing about
planners it's like heroin you know
you're shot into it and then you're like
give me more yeah I can't stop we're
just like where's my supply what's on
the docket for tomorrow
exactly so yes I'm really looking
forward to my planner coming in I can't
me just like everyone I'll do an
unboxing on my planner I'm excited yeah
I know it's gonna be I think and we got
I got nice pens at Paper Source they do
have them at papyrus but I'm you know
what it's like I got in the car and I
was just like wait let me look at the
receipt from paper source because like I
didn't even look like okay and I got six
gel pens and a headband okay
and when I say had been I mean it's like
a paper hey yeah thirty dollars
oh my god that's sunny I think I spend
over $100 what I got like six pens and
then a pack of gel pens the headband and
ponytail a pen with a palm on top
actually no maybe I spent like $70 out
of control yeah that's the price you pay
no damming ahead my new planner is
spiral on the side which I feel like
will be really good
like I have one that's like bound like a
book and it's getting a little like
flimsy no I have a spiral and it's just
that what you find things in your purse
like constantly getting caught in the
spiral that's like my biggest fear my
issue is that my planners is big it's
like a sheet of paper sized so I only
have it with me when I'm carrying really
big personal most of the time it just
stays at home so I have to like go home
and check my planner all the time you
know I understand I can't really be
planning on the go
I plan on the go constant across Tamara
and my banjo planner at the back has
like a million pages for like notes so I
found myself in meetings just like
jotting things down it's just like so
cool it's good for my amnesia it's good
for your brand like to look like you
care right that's the thing okay guys
we're back tomorrow with our final
episode of the week thank you so much
for a great week we'll be recapping Real
Housewives of New York hopefully
tomorrow if I can find the time to watch
two episodes that I missed and thank you
all for being here have a great day bye
you